make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
okay so this is going to sound like it's
coming out of left field so i don't
really expect this video to perform
exceedingly well on the channel uh but
it's one that i've been wanting to make
for a long long time for a couple of
different reasons
the first may or may not become clear
depending on which direction one
division goes
and the second is because of the
direction that one division is going in
and the fact that i think they're going
to launch project wide awake but here on
comics explain because we're trying to
create a clear line between
comics explained and pop culture
explained pop culture explain we'll talk
about how wanda vision ties into all
this right here on comics explained
we're just going to explain project wide
awake so project wide awake was a
long-standing concept in marvel comics
that have been around for a long long
time it initially was introduced with
new mutants issue number one which was
as good a time as any given the nature
of the organization the fact that chris
claremont louise simonson over at marvel
wanted to kind of expand
the idea that mutants were a credible
threat on earth and that different
governments and things like that were
trying to find a way to crack down on
them and and so on and so forth so
for a long long time in marvel comics we
didn't really know
the origins of project wide awake all we
knew was that
somewhere along the line the government
looked at mutants as a credible threat
and then
went forward accordingly this is one of
the significant things that came out of
the story adam the legend of blue marvel
by kevin grievous which was basically
the idea that blue marvel was the reason
why
project wide awake came into existence
or at least was was implemented on a
solid level
by the various governmental authorities
who were out there so the idea here is
that when when adam beshear popped up on
the scene as a superhero
uh and the world learned that he was a
black man of course as most of you guys
know from the adam legend of blue marvel
story the president of president kennedy
at the time
ultimately asked him to step down but in
the aftermath of that
in the aftermath of blue marvel the
concern being that as a black man if he
had sided with like the civil rights
movement for example
and decided to topple the american
government there would have been nothing
they can do
and this led to a string of thoughts
that were taking place in the pentagon
which was
well what happens if it's not somebody
who's part of the civil rights movement
what happens if it's like a communist or
what happens if it's a person who's
disillusioned with the government and is
just crazy and has the power to take the
government down
and there's nothing we can do to stop
them right it turned into a to an
argument of preservation right of saying
like what would happen
if there were a being out there who for
whatever reason chose to target the us
government and destroy us
and there's nothing we could do to stop
them how do we respond to that
and so what you ended up getting was a
couple different things happening at the
same time
the first one was a guy by the name of
judge chalmers who was a federal judge
and because of the fact that he was
existing friends with bolivar trash
combined with his own concerns
about mutant-related issues and issues
coming off the tail of adam bashir he
had commissioned a five-year study
that was designed to basically analyze
the mutant population the potential
powers that mutants could have
and not really to allow flights of
fantasy which is like what if we had one
that could alter reality but to look at
existing evidence and to determine
whether or not mutants were a credible
threat in the united states now senator
robert kelly had done the exact same
thing but the difference here is that
federal judge chalmers
really didn't have any stake in the
five-year plan that he had done outside
of just
analyzing whether or not this was a
credible threat on a legal level right
to kind of get the legal wheels in
motion so that if mutants were arrested
for a particular crime to answer the
question like do they have the same
human rights as everybody else
different things like that right you
know are they bound by the same laws as
the
non-mutant citizen who's out there
senator kelly had done it because he was
staunchly anti-mutant and was looking
for a reason to be able to launch a
campaign
to basically rally those individuals who
were against mutants right because at
the time
mutants were slowly rising into
prominence they weren't necessarily huge
there wasn't a ton of them out there
that people knew
it wasn't really until the early 1960s
going forward that suddenly like the
the number of mutants that existed out
there just started exploding in number
and a lot of that's because of what what
i refer to as the the quote unquote
ticking clock that the celestials had
put into the genes of humans that at
some point along the line
mutants would begin to manifest but
regardless of how you slice it
senator kelly knew that there was a lot
of anti-mutant fear that existed out
there in the country because people are
afraid of what they don't understand
if he could rally that fear and use that
fear for his own ends to become
president of the united states that's
basically what he would do and that's
exactly what he did do and so what you
ended up having was this kind of
idea right these different studies one
that came from senator kelly one that
came from federal judge chalmers which
basically just sat
on desks right that's all it was it was
just this great big huge report that
just sat on a desk somewhere or sat in a
in a drawer somewhere and nobody really
gave it any real thought
until you got to the actions of mystique
and her brotherhood of evil mutants now
this happened in uncanny x-men issues
141-142
with some lead up in issues 139-140 and
a lot of you guys probably know this
story as something called the days of
future past but this is basically a
story where mystique and her second
brotherhood which
actually would eventually go on to
become freedom force uh where they had
basically attacked senator robert kelly
moore mctaggart and charles xavier and
the intention was to assassinate them to
basically demonstrate to people
that mutants should be feared right
mutants are like the next stage of human
evolution
it was a more militaristic stance that
fell more in line with the
idea of magneto and so the result of
this is that you had the initial
timeline the original timeline for days
of future pass where the
where the assassination was successful
but this led to the launch of project
wide awake and the creation of a
sentinels under bolivar trask which
basically became autonomous and then
rationalized
that because mutants are an offshoot of
humanity basically the next stage of
human evolution
that mutants are in fact human and so it
led to sentinels basically conquering
the entirety of the united states and
enslaving both humans and mutants and
then at the end of that story you had
a change in the timeline where rachel
summers the ultimate reality daughter of
jean grey and
cyclops sending the mind of kitty pride
into the past to stop days of future
past from happening which was successful
in in her attempt and so what this meant
was that according to like the main
marvel timeline as we see it
the assassination attempt of of mystique
and her brotherhood of evil mutants
was unsuccessful and while it did not
lead to days of future past what it did
lead to was people coming to the
realization that like
they should read the study of judge
chalmers and the studies of senator
robert kelly and they did
and this basically led to the formation
of project wide awake now project wide
awake was a
multi-faceted intelligence and law
enforcement operation which was for the
most part
completely and totally illegal but the
commission was headed
by the the national security advisor of
the united states and then of course you
had henry peter guyrick who worked for
the national security council who was
head of operations for project wide
awake so making sure
they did their own thing but as far as
this operation goes the main charter was
to contain
and to control and so the the basic gist
was to analyze the entirety of the
mutant threat to find a way to either
contain it to make sure they don't
become a credible threat to the united
states or if at all possible
control the mutant threat and that's
what you saw happen on genocide right
the island of genocide where mutants
were basically kidnapped and taken to
that location
and then thrown there and used as a
labor force now ultimately they were all
eventually freed and that led to
genocide becoming kind of a safe haven
for the mutant population where you had
like 16 million mutants who lived there
and until cassandra nova like massacred
them all right it was insane she
literally killed 16 million mutants in
the span of like four hours it was
it was absolutely bonkers but as far as
the individuals in the organizations
that composed
project wide awake everybody was part of
this so you basically had the cia you
had the fbi you had state sheriff's
office you had the
special assistant to the national
security advisor you had the national
security council
you had local law enforcement the whole
nine yards it was a multi-faceted
illegal operation which was never really
challenged by anybody one because
judge chalmers kind of kept you kind of
stood in the way of anybody presenting a
credible court case to this and two it
just never got to the supreme court
right so there was never really anybody
out there to make the argument that it
couldn't be done
that in the fact that it was kind of
pitched to something that was in the
interest of national security so it was
very easy for the the federal government
to put a lot of red tape around things
and to basically shut down anybody's
ability to look into anything that they
deem to be top secret right because
at that point the freedom of information
act didn't exist so you couldn't go to a
court and say
give like i want all the information
that that exists for a project wide
awake and the court would compel the
government to hand it over
the result of this is that project wide
awake was a very quiet
project or a very quiet system that
existed out there to monitor mutants to
contain mutants and to control mutants
that's what led to bolivar trask
basically creating the sentinel program
as we know it now one of the things to
understand here there's two generations
really even three generations
of sentinels the first one is bolivar
trask which was spearheaded by virtue of
project wide awake the second
went into stephen lang the third went
into operation of national
emergency which we'll talk about that
here in a minute but the important thing
to take away from all this is that with
bolivar trash creating the sentinels it
was the government's way of preparing
themselves against various mutant
threats that existed out there now in
the original x-men stories by stan lee
and jack kirby uh bolivar trask and his
signals were defeated pretty easily
and so what this meant was that it was
easy for the government to just kind of
sweep ball of our trask under the rug
and say we didn't really know anything
about what's going on
obviously we would never sanction
anything like that and under the guise
of project wide awake
secretly take all the information that
belonged to bolivar trask and then hand
it over to stephen lang no relation to
scott lang ant-man right the two of them
were not related but
uh but this basically led to steven lang
creating the more modern sentinels that
you're aware of and so this led into
like the phoenix saga for example when
stephen lange uses sentinels the
information given to him
under project wide awake by the federal
government the research of all of our
trask and then basically going through
capturing a whole bunch of x-men which
led to the other x-men going and
rescuing them and then all of them
flying back to earth and then being hit
by
by a cosmic storm and then jean grey
reaches out to the phoenix and then
becomes a phoenix and so on and so forth
right that's how all that stuff unfolds
now for the most part following the
defeat of stephen lang
project wide awake kind of went away you
had a few things that were there right
you had like freedom force which is
basically mystiques brotherhood of evil
mutants which received a kind of
contract from the government that like
all their crimes would be pardoned
if they carried out like a series of
tasks and things like that so they
basically became a kind of like
government sanctioned
i wouldn't really say like a black ops
team like a black ops wet work team but
like you guys understand the gist of
what they became but for the most part
it kind of vanished but all this came
back
in the aftermath of the onslaught saga
now a lot of you guys who don't know
what the onslaught saga is
this was basically a story there was an
answer to the question what would happen
if charles xavier's frustration with
humanity's desire
to coexist with humans merged with
magneto's pure hatred of humanity what
would that look like and it looked like
onslaught right just
this crazy awesome looking guy he looked
like magneto if he was super shredder he
was really really cool looking now
ultimately onslaught was defeated but
because of the fact that onslaught
raised the credible threat that like
mutants are a lot more dangerous than
humanity previously believed they were
just because of
everything we saw onslaught do taking
over the entirety of new york different
things like that
almost conquering the world and in fact
moving beyond the earth potentially and
conquering the universe depending on
whose power he'd gotten like if he had
taken the power of franklin richards
nate grey different people like that
uh those guys know what that means
they're just super powerful guys who can
in some form or fashion manipulate
reality on different levels
uh basically it led to what was called
operation zero tolerance now operation
zero tolerance was an event that
happened in the aftermath of onslaught
but it dealt with a guy by the name of
bastian
now bastian was not really a person
bastion was a machine
that was originally composed of nimrod
who was a sentinel from the future
in the days of future past event and
master mold who was like the guy that
made sentinels in the modern era the two
of them basically fused and they turned
into bastion as we know him but in the
aftermath of onslaught and because of
the fact that bastian wanted to see
mutants eradicated
bastion managed to successfully petition
the federal government to allow him to
to basically reactivate quote unquote
project wide awake the difference is
that where wide awake was more of an
intelligence gathering apparatus with a
little bit of
you know physical involvement in terms
of launching attacks against mutants
operation zero tolerance the whole the
whole idea of that was just outright
genocide and so it basically
led to to of course you know bastion and
those guys being defeated as senator
robert kelly was the one who originally
signed off on it and then ultimately
changed his mind and said no no i'm not
okay with wiping out the entirety of the
mutant population on earth and then had
shield basically
round up uh bastion and those guys and
that was basically it right they were
all just kind of captured and bastion
did show up a little bit later on but
that was kind of like the the
little tidbit of project wide awake that
you got during that time period now
following that project wide awake
basically went away again and then it
came back
now in this instance it came back in the
aftermath of the events of house of m
uh most of you guys know this as the the
project codenamed
one o e or operation of national
emergency but the whole idea behind this
was that because the scarlet witch had
altered reality and people didn't really
know why
one thing to keep in mind most people
following the events of house of m
didn't remember the events of house of m
right all they knew was that at some
point some weird thing happened and that
was it right the reality was that
scarlet witch had taken
charles xavier of the x-men with these
insane telepathic powers
she had used his mind to subconsciously
figure out the thoughts of everybody on
earth
and then altered reality to give
everybody everything they ever wanted at
the end of that story she basically said
no more mutants and it basically led to
98
of the mutant population losing their
powers and so in response to that the
federal government had two different
ideas the first one was to look at it
from the perspective of okay
mutants are actual citizens by this
point senator robert kelly had moved
away from being starsly anti-mutant and
had actually become a supporter of
mutant rights
uh and then at the same time you had a
guy by the name of general laser he's
not really important
the important thing is he was part of
the group that believed that this was
the best chance to eradicate the mutant
population
right i mean previously before before
the events of house of m you had like
millions of mutants
now you had 198 of them and they were
all
at the xavier institute right why not
just nuke the place
[Laughter]
now of course public sentiment at the
time was such that it would not have
gone over well for the federal
government if they had just
nuked the mutant population because um
the the average non-mutant person aside
from the most extreme groups like
friends of humanity or the right or any
of those guys they would have seen it as
like kicking somebody while they're down
right and so most people wouldn't have
sided with that which kind of kept the
the hands of general laser tied to a
degree
but the overall gist was with office
national emergency they created what
were called the one sentinels which were
basically these manned sentinels and
they they use that because they realize
the problem with having
any kind of sentinel out there that
abides by programming is given events
that we'd seen with like master mold the
potential for days of future past things
like that as that signals abide by
absolute programming they don't really
understand new ones and so when you look
at things where you know
senator robert kelly and those guys
learned that in an alternate reality
that sentinel's come to the conclusion
that mutants are effectively humans in
the next stage of evolution
that mutants and humans are the same
thing and so they end up capturing you
know and basically controlling the whole
of north america to prevent that from
happening
they basically had people control the
signals and it kind of worked for the
most part but the whole point behind
that is you basically had them just sort
of safeguarding the mutant population
now i say safeguarding but it was really
more just a prison right mutants
couldn't leave the xavier institute but
nobody could get in either right so they
were
as much prisoners as they were you know
people who were being protected it's one
of those weird and kind of wonky
situations but the reality is that's
kind of where it stopped now office and
national emergency did kind of have a
lot going on
in terms of their role it wasn't
necessarily just sentinels it really was
kind of safeguarding and protecting
having like manned men's soldiers that
were guarding a perimeter things along
those lines and they had a little bit of
involvement later on but as far as the
whole
of the project wide awake uh series of
events this is not really to be confused
with something like weapons plus
it's not really to be confused with like
the commission on superhuman activities
it's not designed to be confused with
those different things project wide
awake was a holy separate
entity that was initially spearheaded by
the government and then just kind of
went away once
once they realized that things like that
just didn't work in some ways it was
kind of replaced for example like if you
look at the events of civil war and you
look at superhuman registration
superhuman registration required that
anybody who had superpowers in the
united states had to register their
powers and their names and addresses
their information with shield
so that kind of replaced the idea of the
commission on superhuman activities the
idea of like project wide awake even
though project wide awake was largely a
an anti-mutant or a mutant based concept
mutants were kind of given a little bit
of license
by by shield at the time which didn't
really matter because there were so few
the office of national emergency was
already monitoring them anyway uh so
again you know
as far as this goes project wide awake
was a really really cool concept that
was born from the chris claremont era of
x-men but over the years has just
kind of faded away into oblivion and
marvel comics so with that being said
guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
you